pour plus de solidarité dans la
distribution des vaccins
l' oms et l'alliance pour les vaccins
ont mis en place le kovacs un mécanisme
permettant d'acquérir des doses pour les
redistribuer aux pays les plus pauvres
alors que la compétition fait rage pour
obtenir des vaccins les plus riches sont
ceux qui s'en sortent le mieux
à eux seuls ils ont préempté la moitié
des 8 milliards de doses prévues les
pays à plus faible revenu soit les
quatre cinquièmes de la population
doivent eux se partagent et l'autre
moitié une disparité vivement critiqué
par le ms j'exhorte les pays et les
fabricants à cesser de conclure des
accords bilatéraux au détriment du
kovacs aucun pays n'est exceptionnelle
edwards et skier et vacciner toute sa
population alors que certains restent
sans approvisionnement en vaccins with
no name
cet appel intervient alors que l'union
européenne a doublé cette semaine ses
précommandes du vaccin pfizer biotech
lieu qui avec les etats-unis le canada
le royaume uni et l'inde fait partie de
ceux qui ont acheté le plus de doses des
accords tous azimuts qui ont eu pour
conséquence de faire grimper les prix
rendant le vaccin encore plus
inaccessible aux pays pauvres
le kovacs permettraient de mutualiser
les achats de doses et de les
redistribuer dans l'unique cadre de ce
mécanisme
faisant ainsi du vaccin un bien public
mondial vaccination or le nationalisme
vaccinale nous fait du mal à tous et est
voué à l'échec
mais d'un autre côté la vaccination
équitable sauvent des vies stabilise des
systèmes de santé et conduirait à une
véritable reprise économique mondiale
qui stimulerait la création d'emplois
vacciner équitablement les populations
pour lutter contre le virus sans
aggraver les inégalités c'est là l'autre
défi de cette pandémie